with blood and fire the gangs of
assailants whip the supply center
the man with the number 14 jersey is
a fruit merchant arranges his
merchandise calmly suddenly
three men with caps appear they are
assailants start a struggle to
get the cash that he brings between his
clothes the victim tries to defend himself with
blows for a few seconds they struggle the
man dressed in a sweatshirt carries a
gun in his hand and at all times points it at
him when he sees that he cannot subdue
him he shoots him and immediately escapes with his
accomplices crime does not give up
in the  corridors of the largest market
in Latin America
how can we work one hundred percent
all the people yes with uncertainty
with their works we as a merchant
in the community at any time
something that should not happen can happen to us
that for a lawsuit they are
wherever they used to be  no you believe in the
city wherever you want but more here because of the
movement that there is not after the
stock market  e values ​​is the place where there is more
to the more circulating one I see you had
videos of the security cameras that
the merchants of the
supply center have placed to have a witness
of the crimes it is the same modus
operandi at five in the morning with
four minutes the subject with a gray cap
pulls out a firearm and points it at his
victim immediately his henchmen
jump on the merchant to
strip him of his wallet and cell phone
we here in the warehouse have
been robbed about five times from 2004
to 2013 to here  We have been robbed about
five times and the truth is that they arrive and
they are gangs, they are a group of 67
people, they all come armed, well,
all of you take out your gun and you don't
get a chance for anything
in this other video from February 22, one
of  The criminals posed as a
diablero and I serve that appears to be
bought or what this buyers appear to do
and they arrive apparently from the
fruit, it reaches this level that they  people
are working and where they see that they
can take advantage they
immediately take out the gun,
direct all the people and
organize them and grab tangos of
t-shirts, double-sided sweatshirts,
even have trout when they
become ready, they immediately take
off their sweatshirts or leave  They remove their
hoods and go among the trucks on
a tour 1 TV shows all the
security deficiencies One of the
reasons why criminals
can do their thing here at the
central de abastos is that only 80
police officers are designated to monitor
more  Out of 329 hectares of the largest market
in Latin America,
there was only one policeman in one corridor and
some areas were dark due to
failures in the
electricity service. On different occasions,
merchants from the supply center
have demonstrated against
insecurity and have even  tried to take
justice into their own hands in the face of a
problem that they say is not only  It affects
them, but also the 450,000
clients that the plant receives per day and
where a cash flow moves
only below the stock market.